l'ancien politicien léo bureau blouin a
subi une chirurgie pour réparer des
ligaments au genou
pourtant ce n'est pas leur taupe existe
qui l'a opéré qui fait le suivi mais
plutôt la physiothérapeute manon pilon
à l'évidence la guérison va très bien
et parce qu'il n'y a pas d'autres
interventions à faire
léo bureau-blouin n'aura pas à revoir
leur taupe existe l'important était
surtout d'avoir accès aux soins
spécialisés la santé qui connaît le
jeunot qui connaît ma situation s'est un
peu rassuré répondre à mes questions
puis je pense qu'ils me rassois aussi
c'est que je sais que le médecin paul
ont ainsi jamais s'il ya des
complications à la clinique externe
d'orthopédie de l'hôpital jean-talon les
physiothérapeutes font la majorité des
cartes et apparaît 75% 75 % n'ont pas
besoin de voir un orthopédiste
étant donné que encore une fois on a
déjà parlé c'est des capucins peuvent
être vues directement par les
professionnels l'orthopédiste julio
fernandes est l'instigateur de cette
clinique unique dans le secteur
hospitalier au québec
il apprécié l'implication accrue des
physiothérapeutes même à ça mais ça fait
plaisir parce que ça me libère pour les
cas plus complexes
ça me libère une journée où par exemple
je pourrais aller en salle d'opération
et il intervient pour les cas plus
complexes comme celui d'al elle aliot
qui a chuté d'un deuxième étape
séparation comparer la luxation
il pense que les physiothérapeutes sont
la solution à la teinte en orthopédie
imaginez qu'on a trois cent mille
consultations par année si on avait 180
physio au québec à 2000 patients par
année on verrait 360 me passer on
pourrait absorber toute la demande de
l'année avec 181 physiothérapeute bien
des pays comme l'irlande qui compte cinq
millions d'habitants se sont aussi
tournés vers les physiothérapeutes
en implantant 25 physiothérapeute en
pratique avancée en irlande on a réussi
à diminuer les temps d'attentes de 50
pour ça mais comme c'est le cas pour
l'implication des infirmières le québec
est même en retard par rapport à
d'autres provinces en ontario les
auteurs peuvent prescrire plus
d'imagerie peuvent faire des injections
articulaires québec continue à analyser
la pertinence de déléguer davantage aux
physiothérapeutes pour soulager les
orthopédistes qui sont débordées
ici david gêne-t-il airs et au canada
montréal